david shooters are in a weird place
right now we've got call of duty
creeping on battlefields large scale
modes again and we got fortnite getting
rid of building which is kind of their
thing and we got battlefield actually
making changes six months later and
admitting their heroes weren't such a
great idea but we'll see if that could
save the franchise or what else i can do
next so let's talk about how odd
everything is what's going on right now
there's been some recent changes in the
past couple weeks and you know where we
think we're we're going next
let's start with battlefield i was out
when season one got delayed like for me
that was the deal breaker i was actually
not as upset with a lot of the things
that other people were but i understand
people hated the um
the specialists and the way they came
away from the class system but the
minute season one was delayed it was
like
how how did you not have this
in the can already
like what what happened there yeah no
it's funny you mentioned that because
for me it was um there was a bug on pc
back you know like uh not too long i
mean they put out an update you know i
did there was like an nvidia update and
stuff because frame rates were so bad
even if you had a souped-up pc because i
think it was running off of like your
cpu instead of your graphics card so
everything was just being super
bottlenecked and there was a moment
literally on origin where i logged in
and i couldn't move
you couldn't move at all like you
couldn't even turn and i for me i just
threw my hands up i was like i'm out of
here like i can't so that's the thing
that's kind of baffling and let me read
you just one of these changes here so
uh small theme changes to match the
original trailer
the original trailer was gritty and the
world was super clean
shorter runs between bases fewer attack
vehicles so they're
they're making fewer attack vehicles so
there's less things killing you while
you're running across it right
more mud more cover
so like a summary is basically they're
addressing
a lot of community feedback around
you're running too far distances between
objectives and
um you're getting killed by too many
things and there's not enough cover
while you're doing it
so right do you think those changes are
i don't know are we heading the right
direction how do you feel about it
yeah i think so you know i think um the
two the two main changes so fewer
vehicles and less distance are kind of
hand in hand you know what i mean
because if you just remove the vehicles
from the calling system so you're dying
less from cheap you know
campy cheesy vehicles but then you're
stuck hoofing it from one sector to the
other sector and i think that whole like
style of having these sectors uh be so
spaced out was kind of a pain point for
a lot of folks especially on certain
maps like off the top of my head you had
orbital which had this like long runway
to the to like the space shuttle and i
mean that was just like
it was a celebrity
i mean it was a sniper's you know dream
but it was so annoying you know trying
to get from one spot to the other half
the time i would just you know actually
kill myself so i could reload in on the
other side of the map faster than you
know trying to go on foot so i think the
shorter runs between the bases and
having more transport vehicles for that
is um actually a fun change i think
that'd be really good it's interesting
too about them adding in more objectives
that feel grittier i think a lot of
people have mentioned this but it was
surprisingly
off-putting
how different the game was from the
trailers like we thought we were getting
modern warfare 2019 that was kind of
like our baseline well we were gonna get
this gritty world and they were gonna
tell us stories with cutscenes in
between seasons and then you showed up
in this like supposedly just ravished
world
climate change ravished world and it was
like
super they looked like clean janitors
had just like gone to town on every
level like
it looked way too clean it looked way
too yeah it looked way too ordinary now
the other thing that they've been
talking about and apparently is going to
be the next set of announcements which
might be next month is they're
trying to cram those specialists back
down into classes
and they even at one point they were
gonna do a hero shooter where are we at
on that
oh my gosh so yeah i think uh with the
the hero shooter that you mentioned is
kind of funny so you know there was some
reports that for the next battlefield
entry they were considering supposedly
doubling down on specialists adding more
heroes and you know the community
feedback and all the response from the
from the fan base
clearly gave them that red flag when
they were like okay this is actually an
awful idea yeah no i think everybody
just wants
classes back and we just want classes we
just want our operators that's it you
know what's really interesting too is
they didn't think through the classes
enough very specific example is sundance
should have been countered by boris
right like you think about it in terms
of overwatch who counters who sundance
flies boris has a turret that shoots
things down it was like such an obvious
play counter play i think people also
really want them to look different so
like put them in the faction so you know
who you're looking at and like what they
can do at any given time
and to top it all off like just the
icing on the cake is somehow they put
the shotgun bug back in the game from
battlefield 3. now this boss 12.
i like a long time ago i made a video
where i was like is frostbite the
problem
and it's laughable in the sense that
battlefield was built on frostbite it
wouldn't exist without frostbite but
after seeing frostbite then be failed
in its adaptation to so many other games
like mass effect andromeda and see it'd
still be a problem for the game it was
designed for
yeah i think frostbite is the problem
like i just think they need to like tear
that whole engine down to the ground and
just
start again i know that costs a lot of
money
but like
i can't think of another solution right
now it seems to be outdated because how
do these bugs keep slipping in left and
right and you know again when when
your most avid defenders are telling
everyone no no guys it's okay the game's
supposed to be buggy at launch they're
gonna fix it later then you know what
are you doing right you've got
you you got the chips kind of stacked
against you at this point so secretly i
kind of want to see what happens in
season one i'm willing to come back and
play a little bit but it's lost most of
the people most people won't come back
right right maybe if it goes free to
play but we'll just have to see i
understand that you're all gone and
that's the end of that but it is
interesting to see where their heads at
so let's talk about fortnight now it's
really interesting and like you know we
don't show people behind the scenes too
much of game spot but a lot of times we
just sit around talking about games and
david i think you just the other day in
a meeting were like dude fortnite's
killing it like they're
they've they're dude they're still doing
things that nobody else is doing what
are your thoughts on this no building
mode so i think that the no building
mode is
just a gift from epic right now at least
at least for people like me you know and
and the main thing about no building is
that it kind of
it both addresses two things in my mind
one it addresses the fact that epic is
very um versatile for better or worse
depending on you know how well they're
able to adopt a certain trends like
really quickly as a quick side note you
know among us was such a very popular
game and fortnite kind of blatantly like
almost plagiarized it and so there's
some
areas of epics like quick on the cuff uh
pivots that i don't i'm not really too
fond of because it seems like they're
just stealing other people's better
ideas but on the other end it also shows
that there's
one thing there it actually started as a
tower defense game because that's what
was popular when it started
and it changed on a dime to battlefield
because because of pub g right it was
yeah i think pubg like took off and so
fortnite was like oh here we go yeah i
mean so it's kind of like their mo right
but at the same time it also proves the
fact that they're so
they always have their finger on the
trigger and they have another finger on
the pulse like at all times and so i
think one of the things that they've
noticed is you know fortnite's audience
um tends to skew very younger right
you've got these cracked out kids that
are making skyscrapers in like two to
three seconds and it just doesn't feel
good uh you know doing your best getting
a couple of kills along the way
just to
go on a one-on-one with some dude who
playing on his lunch on the ipad and
just like
absolutely destroying you right and you
know you could be a good shot but it
doesn't matter because and those final
duels it's the better builder wins
usually right having a no build zone it
kind of like
evens the playing field a little bit and
it's like all right it's you it's your
gun and it's your it's your trigger
finger basically you know
go and so i really uh
i i i really respect that and i think
you know they know too like i mean epic
knows that the
epic knows that the feedback has been so
positive they seem to have kind of like
rotated it into a permanent ltm which is
which is awesome i took some quick notes
for this conversation because i went
back and played a bit time to kill is
still very long compared to other battle
royale games which i think kind of makes
it unique
so you could you actually have those
fire fights they're not over in a flash
in fortnite you can carry down teammates
which is actually very forward thinking
i think battlefield battlefield was
originally supposed to have that feature
and then it just never made it into the
game but it's so helpful to be able to
carry somebody off of a ridge and revive
them undercover
and then
they have pv pve player verse player
versus environment and a ton of
activities to do outside of just the
battle royale but like if you're not
trying to win a battle royale game
it can get very boring or if you just
don't have the skill to win but like
they have all the stuff you can do and
you don't even have to worry about
winning weirdly like they've started
also doing that thing they do you you
just said it a minute ago they started
becoming like other games a bit more
taking their ideas so tax prints in the
game revive stations are in the game
um you could ping people after apex kind
of like you know brought that up
there's also like vehicles and tanks now
so
it's this trend of like games being
their own thing and then kind of slowly
walking it back over the years but like
fortnite is just the great like
i don't know how to put it it just eats
every other game it can do what every
other game can do
sometimes better
which is why
i was actually gonna save this for
another part of the conversation but
like this is why hazard zone is never
gonna work in battlefield it's because
there's games like fortnight and there's
games like call of duty which i think i
want to talk about right now
um
that have these
systems that are so adaptable they can
just do whatever battlefield does so
like warzone can just try a hazard zone
for a weekend without even thinking
about it right so how do you compete
against something like that
so call of duty is in a really good
position right now you know we're
talking about this before war zone is
very adaptable although there's a lot of
problems with it right now but more
importantly vanguard just dropped arms
race and arms race is really good arms
race is kind of like if you combine
conquest with like obliteration from
battlefield obliteration being like it's
almost like a run the football kind of
mode
so
what happens in this mode is you
basically you start you drop on
objectives you capture those objectives
and then a ball drops on the field and
what you do is one team grabs the ball
they take it back to a base and that
base explodes so that conquest point is
gone it like solves all the problems in
my mind that 128 player conquest had in
battlefield which is just
either everything's like too wide open
and you're running all over the place
or it's like too many people just
channeled into one spot and there's no
way for you to survive or have any say
over the game what arms race does that
solves this problem is it starts to fuse
but then as conquest points get
destroyed then everybody gets channeled
into these different places and the flow
is like variable so you sometimes you're
attacking or defending a base sometimes
you're making that end run behind the
other team to capture something and
sometimes you're fighting over what is
equivalent of like a bomb or a football
so i think call of duty still has it
like even though a lot of people are not
going to play vanguard because it's just
kind of meh i i'll admit it though if my
review my review of vanguard would be
that it beat it it's like
it's
it's totally adequate it's not bad it's
not great it's just it's it's fine like
it's totally fine
it's another cod i don't hate it i don't
love it it's just i play it sometimes
so they're in a good position they have
these creative thoughts
now here's what just happened though
with the war zone let's talk about the
problems and sort of the next steps
warzone was was fantastic and it was so
successful that they tried to cram cold
war into it and then they tried to cram
vanguard into it and what they wound up
doing was getting rid of her dance the
map or just fundamentally changing time
to kill in ways that just wasn't fun
anymore and what they've admitted now is
they can't
rotate maps the way apex can
um because the file sizes are just
insane though you know
yeah you just can't do you can't cram
that they're like at one point modern
warfare was well over 200 gigs and it's
it's it's small yeah it was like a whole
hard drive right like so where they're
at now is they need to rebuild this
whole thing the ground up with modern
warfare
2 or whatever it's called it's a sequel
to modern warfare that's confirmed and
they are they're building the whole
thing from the ground up so i kind of
hope they wipe the slate clean and start
over again
and they don't have this thing that
happens where they have to cram every
new call of duty game into warzone
because it's leading to this problem you
cannot rotate maps file sizes are too
big
people who don't like vanguard suddenly
or cold war suddenly got ejected from
their favorite
like call of duty game which was let's
be honest war zone was modern warfare
2019 it was
all of the same maps in one map so
that's kind of where we're at on that we
we're never going to get or at least not
not in the near future we're not going
to get like things like field of view
slider and we're not going to get
rotating maps but all that could now
happen with modern warfare 2. so it's
exciting we're in a decent place right
now with call of duty if people just
have a little bit of patience it'll
it'll be at the end of this year
all right guys so as you can see
shooter's in a really weird place right
now we just broke down call of duty
fortnite and battlefield and we want to
hear your guys's hot takes so hit us
with those comments like and subscribe
we'll feature some of your comments next
week and let us know alright thanks
everybody for watching
you